well on the right to bear arms the ACL
u--'s position is that there is not a
fundamental civil liberty to unregulated
gun ownership and that's separate and
apart from the big constitutional law
debate that's going on now in a case
before the Supreme Court and it is
important for people to know that the
only path Supreme Court decisions that
have discussed this issue and the vast
majority of scholarship and lower courts
and historians conclude that the second
amendment was intended only to protect
the right to bear arms in the context of
a well-regulated militia for us that's
of interest but it's a separate question
from should do we think that a statute
should be passed to protect unregulated
gun ownership the answer is no and to me
that's not so surprising because we even
when it comes to something that we are
classically associated with such as
freedom of speech we don't say that you
know there can never be any restrictions
actually no right is absolute except
freedom of thought and freedom of belief
but once it gets out of your head and
into the world the government may
justifiably impose limits in very narrow
circumstances so if the government over
regulated or discriminatorily or
arbitrarily enforce regulations on gun
ownership we would be there I mean that
would be consistent with our general
concepts of due process and in fact we
have often collaborated including
post-911 with the National Rifle
Association gun owners of america the
Second Amendment Foundation because
particular actions that have been taken
by the government against their members
do in fact violate many rights including
you know to take some examples that come
from earlier during the Clinton
administration the Waco and Ruby Ridge
incidents were well publicized examples
of really a shock
government overreaching by federal
agencies that were you know violating
the Fourth Amendment rights against
search and seizure using
disproportionate force shooting to kill
people who are simply suspected of
exercising what is after all a legally
protected right to to bear arms and
there have been many examples of
people's privacy being violated because
they are exercising their now lawful
right to own guns the the gun owners
organizations have worked very closely
with the ACLU in opposing government
surveillance the so-called real ID act
that would create a national identity
card in effect so there's a lot of
overlapping issues even beyond that core
issue up to what extent can the
government directly regulate gun
ownership